I told you guys this I think you and
Michael mice the other night I Einstein
when the Nazis were coming to power he
saw it early and got out of the country
and fled to the United States and people
have already fled the US I am I'm
feeling that right now and I don't like
that but that is what I feel and what I
see is like yo if Mass illegal
immigration record high inflation World
Wars all popping up all over the place
the people arresting their political
opponents like okay guys and I don't
want to black pill you and I don't want
to give up on this wonderful
Constitution we got but what does the
country even mean is it the land that
you live on is it the Constitution
that's bit is it the people that are
running the military like what is this
country I mean that's the question right
I don't know where you would like to go
if you were to leave the us one of the
ISS Salvador El Salvador maybe I mean
there are interesting places